hello there
reject nation
i've been experiencing so much anxiety
right now
i never um or not i wouldn't say never
but
rarely do come on the channel and do a
video where i'm just gonna
get a little serious right now
just the the the election just following
this election
of today it's not done yet but it's just
giving me
so much anxiety and i'm sure there's
plenty of people out there who are
feeling
tense as well anxious as well it's a
tight race at the moment
um
it's just just like
it's one of those things where it's like
i'm on twitter i'm on social media i'm
like i need to stop looking at social
media and then i'm like on youtube and
i'm watching
all different kinds of videos i'm
looking at different tv programs
it's just i'm like oh man my mind's
becoming so consumed i know a lot of you
guys are probably out there
maybe doing the same thing right now or
maybe you're just avoiding it i don't
know
i really felt it earlier today it was
like kicking in
um i went to the store it went to
ralph's
or maybe in some other parts of the
world they call it king supers
and uh when i was there
it was packed and just
the conversations from all these
strangers
everyone was like it was the people were
just stockpiling on
everything and then i've been hearing
about like stores boarding up stores
closing down
um you know doctors canceling
appointments for the rest of the week
there's been a lot of places that are
really concerned about you know looting
and rioting and
you know violent acts in the streets and
whatnot and i'm
i'm just uh you know it's it's
i've heard people say like if biden wins
it's for sure gonna happen
if trump wins it's for sure gonna happen
i was like okay so if either one of them
wins it's for sure gonna happen
no matter who wins
i do not want that to happen i don't
think it'll
do us any good for for that to happen
that's my personal opinion some people
are all for it
and uh i don't think it will do any good
and i just want everyone to be like
just try to be conscientious and
you know try to be kind to each other
yeah i'm i don't know i don't really
know the point of doing this is i'm just
popping on here
maybe i can serve as a a way to i
identify with someone out there who's
listening to this or maybe
um
maybe this isn't doing anything it's
just me venting to you guys i don't know
maybe it's doing both but yeah
i hope everyone out there is doing okay
i hope you guys are able to stay safe
let's just try to be more loving